buenas tardes el primer ministro boris
johnson y el jefe científico que asesora
al gobierno en estos asuntos ofrecerán
esta tarde una rueda de prensa para
detallar cuál será ese plan que tiene el
gobierno y las autoridades de salud para
evitar que esta variante omicron los que
se han detectado como lo mencionas dos
casos hoy aquí en inglaterra se propague
y se convierta la dominante y entonces
ponga en riesgo la vacunación que ha
sido bien exitosa aquí en este país por
ahora se ha anunciado por parte del
ministro de salud que se van a
monitorear de una manera mucho más
fuertes los casos que den positivo en
las zonas de chelmsord en el sur de
inglaterra y en nottingham en el centro
norte para dar determinar rápidamente a
través de pruebas pcr que esta variante
no se ha extendido mucho más eso es lo
que se quiere determinar porque esa es
la gran preocupación en este momento
también las personas dos que han dado
positivo para esta variante de omicron
se mantienen aisladas así como sus
familias trate de frenar se la
propagación además el gobierno anunciado
que a partir de mañana a las 4 de la
mañana de este domingo otros cuatro
países africanos ingresan a su lista
roja de viajes esto es decir no se
permite el ingreso directo salvo con una
cuarentena de 10 días en un hotel que
deben pagar estas personas para poder
ingresar al reino unido- de estos países
son angola mozambique malawi zambia así
que estamos atentos a cuál puede ser ese
paquete de medidas que se van a usar el
primer ministro en las próximas horas
luisa eso en cuanto a reino unido pero
que puede decirnos del panorama de
europa frente a esta nueva variante
hay mucho nerviosismo europa puede
decirse está en máxima alerta por la
posibilidad de que esta variante omicron
que es altamente contagiosa tendría al
menos 30 mutaciones ya esté en su
territorio por ahora y altas sospechas
pero no certezas hoy en el aeropuerto de
amsterdam 61 personas dieron positivo
por kobe 19 pero hasta el momento no se
conoce si para esta variante de omicron
estas personas llegaron al aeropuerto de
amsterdam como les digo de sudáfrica en
dos vuelos además se conoce un caso
altamente probable en alemania y otro en
la república checa pero todavía no hay
esa certeza por eso europa las
autoridades sanitarias y los gobiernos
están trabajando conjuntamente para
evitar su expansión y su llegada